b
good evening everybody
welcome to our public lecture
i'm david krakauer i'm the president of the
center for institute and uh i want to thank
the mckinnon family foundation for their support
but also of course the lensic and the reporter
tonight's speaker is ricardo hausmann he's the
founder and director of harvard's growth lab
and a professor of practice at the harvard
kennedy school he's also much more importantly a
member of our external faculty and co-chairs
the science board the science board is the
sort of remote sensing long range
board of the center fence to jew
ricardo i should just say has one of those
cvs that if you pick up feels like a cv
multiple tvs that you've somehow picked
up seven people's cvs and then you realize
that it's one person's and you think who
is this person i mean how did he do this
and uh it's that sort of breadth of interest and
depth of interest that makes him interesting to us
um ricardo was chief economist of
the inter-american development bank
between 94 and 2000 where he created the research
department he served as the minister of planning
for venezuela between 92 and 93 and a member
of the board of the central bank of venezuela
he's also someone special because he bridges
foundational theory and policy and practice so
that would be like taking a theoretical physicist
who works in particle physics and asking them to
fix your car and so from personal experience
i can tell you that'd be a very bad idea
uh but ricardo is one of those people who pulls
it off which is very special so in that hybrid
capacity uh just to give you some examples of
projects that ricardo has worked on with the
united nation he worked on a research initiative
to promote sustainable and inclusive prosperity in
south africa with the moore foundation advancing
economic development and environmental stability
in the amazonian states in colombia with the u.s
agency for international development advancing
economic diversity diversification in ethiopia
so he has an extraordinary range of interests
and has a real impact on the world so with
that i'll turn it over to our friend ricardo
thank you thank you thank you good evening it's
it's really an honor and a pleasure to be here
thanks david for that kind introduction
as they say my father would have appreciated
it and my mother would have believed it
in a i am super proud of my affiliation
with the santa fe institute i have an
enormous amount of fun at the institute and
i enjoy myself enormously in the restaurants
and the trails in santa fe so i'm super
happy to be here today i'm going to try to
describe to you how more or less i see the world
hello
i'm um uh an economist a development economist
i care about generating prosperity in the world
now what the hell am i doing
in a complexity science
institute what's the connection so i guess in this
lecture i'm going to try to make it clear why why
complexity is so important to understand
important issues in the world today so
i care about prosperity and prosperity
is something that started with this guy
this is adam smith okay and and he you
know wrote you know the wealth of nations
while the origins and causes the nature
and causes of the wealth of nations
okay so he was worried there were some
rich countries and some poor countries
when he wrote that book in 1776 it's a number
that probably reminds you of other things 1776
the richest country in the world was the
netherlands and it's a it was about four
times richer than the poorest country in the world
and we know what the poorest country in the world
must have been because they were at subsistence
so they were at four times subsistence that was
the richest country in the world so if you look at
the world today the poorest country in the world
is by statistics malawi okay so it's not
malawi it competes with others but more or less
so let's apply the adam smith rule right of
multiplying by four the income per capita of the
poorest country to get to the richest country
well if you multiply by four you get to haiti
which is the poorest country in this hemisphere
my own country venezuela is trying to displace
haiti but that's a different story if you
multiply by 4 haiti you get to morocco
if you multiply by 4 in morocco you get to poland
and if you multiply by 4
poland you get to singapore
so a problem that was a problem of 4 to 1
leading to such an important book
became somehow a problem of 256 to 1.
so it's kind of like scientific proof that the
problem doesn't go away by reading adam smith
so we understand a little bit of what happened
what happened is that incomes per capita
forever were flat since the year zero
and then they started to grow about 200 years
ago and if we zoom into the last 200 years you
know something happened in some parts of
the world that sort of like didn't happen
in other parts of the world so if you measure the
differences in income here you know they're small
if you measure them over here they're huge right
so we want to understand what the hell happened
and you know there's an argument you know what
happened is the industrial revolution but the
reason why some countries did it and other
countries were left behind well before i go
there let me just show you a picture of what
these differences are these differences look
like this right so this is a picture of say
low income this is a picture of high income
and i don't know what what you see here i'm
gonna go come back to these pictures but um
what is really puzzling to me is that
it's possible to take this picture
because if i hadn't asked you to take a
picture of a typing machine typewriter
where would you find one there are no typewriters
i mean the museums right so how come this place
this thing is not in a museum this is in real
life why has it not been displaced by just better
cheaper machines right why did this technology
not displace the other technology you might want
to ask so the typical answer the most popular
answer these days among my colleagues is to say
look it's all in the institutions it's it's you
know this book famous book why nations fail from
dharanas asemoglu who's at mit and jim robinson
who used to be at harvard now he's at chicago says
you know the problem is that some countries have
good institutions and that generates incentives to
to to use technology and others have lousy
institutions and that generates disincentives
and as a consequence you know it's all in the
institutions and the book starts uh with a story
of the two nogales nogales arizona and nogales so
they're not too far away the book starts okay so
no locales arizona is rich and sonora they're
right across the river so what could it be
it has to be institutions what the book didn't
tell you is that if you look within mexico
one of the poorest states in
mexico is the state of guerrero
it's in the south if you multiply by two the
income per capita of guerrero you get to sinaloa
guerrero has an income per capita like
that of say honduras and sinaloa has an
income per capita say of that like jamaica if
you multiply by two the state of sinalog you
get to the state of guanajuato which has an
income per capita say like that of malaysia
and if you multiply by two the state of
guanajuato you get two states of nuevo which has a
productivity slightly higher than that of korea so
this these productivity gaps are in the same legal
framework in the same federal judicial system
in the same a political representation system
in the same ex with the same exchange rate the
same interest rate the same macroeconomic setup
the same financial architecture you get these huge
differences in incomes per capita within country
so what the hell is going on by the way these
differences dwarf the difference between nogales
arizona so what the hell is going on and i'm going
to argue that maybe the problem is that technology
does not diffuse but not because of institutions
but because of the nature of technology itself
okay and i'm going to i need to then explain what
what the hell do i mean by technology and and then
i'm going to build on that and by technology i'm
going to mean essentially productive knowledge
knowledge that we use to transform the world
as it is to the world as we wish it were like
as we wanted to be right you're in front
of a beautiful landscape a beautiful field
and a meadow in a valley but you don't want
the meadow in the valley you want an omelet
so how do you go from a meadow
in a valley to an omelet
well you know you have to produce eggs you
have to produce cheese you have to produce this
well so you have to transform the world that
you find and how do you transform the world
by using productive knowledge knowledge about
doing things in the world and this knowledge
takes three forms okay the first form it takes
it takes the form of tools and materials the
knowledge on how to make the tools and materials
is in the tool or the material you don't need to
know how to do it you just need access to the
tool that knowledge is embodied in the tool
the knowledge is embodied in codes recipes
formulas algorithms how to do manuals cookbooks
okay and as such this lives in some symbolic
space right this is ink over paper but it's
not in the ink it's not in the paper if you
take a picture of the ink and the paper like
this guy has done here it doesn't change
the meaning of the picture right so
it's in the form of codes recipes and
so on and if this is all there was
then the world would be flat technology would be
everywhere because the tools we can ship around
and if the market won't do it we'll create
an ngo and we will just ship them around
the codes we can put on the web and we can share
them with anybody that has a smartphone right
but i said that there were three things and
i've only mentioned two and to guess what
the third one is you have to ask yourself the
question what do you do when you're two-thirds
and you know one pause in in some
universe the answer would have been
you download an article from the web and ask your
significant other to follow the instructions right
but you don't do that right you don't do that you
go to a dentist and the dentist uses tools the
dentist follows protocols but the dentist mixes
the tools and the protocols with something you
and i don't have which is the ability to look into
the mouth and see things we would not have noticed
and the ability to use the tools in ways
that we don't know how to use the tools
and that thing that third thing is something
we want to call know-how or tacit knowledge
something that is in his brain and exists only
in brains it does not exist in books it does not
exist in other instantiations it only exists
in brains okay so the problem with technology
is that a to implement it you need tools codes and
know-how you need all three in some combination
and the tools and codes are easy to share
but don't know how it's hard to move
know how is the ability to perform a task
right now for example here is raphael and
he knows how to perform this task right
i mentioned this because i guarantee you
that a conversation with rafa nadal is
not going to improve your tennis
game so this is not information
it's not something you communicate it's a
wiring of the brain and by the way it does
not involve understanding example i'm showing to
you at this very moment that i know how to walk
but it doesn't mean that i
know anything about walking
i don't know which muscles i move i don't know how
i keep my balance i don't know how i get just my
heartbeat and my breathing speed and so on i don't
know any of that my brain does i have no access
to it and i wouldn't teach my grandchildren
to walk by explaining the concepts right so
so know how is this funny thing if you would say
most of it is not in the prefrontal cortex if you
know it's not something that we do consciously
it's something that's been wired into our brain
and the problem with technology is that it's
not just individual know-how it's team know-how
it's knowledge that is distributed in
a group of people that can implement
a certain function so you might say that this
pilot here knows how to implement this technology
but that would be imprecise language to implement
this technology you need all these other people
without all these other people the technology
doesn't work so technologies presume a network
of people with complementary knowledge that are
needed to implement that particular technology
so i'm going to argue that the difference
between rich countries and poor countries
is essentially differences in know-how
if it was differences in tools and codes
we would have solved the problem long
time ago its differences in know-how
know-how gets into brains with enormous difficulty
malcolm gladwell says it takes 10 000 hours to
become good at something i don't know that i we
need to believe that statistic but i just note
that 10 000 hours at 40 hours a week maybe if you
take a little bit vacation 15 days vacation or so
well it will take you five years and we don't have
chunks of five years to spare that's one of the
scientific explanations for why your
dentist tends not to be your lawyer
right so
i'm now going to try to measure know-how
and the way i'm going to measure know-how is i'm
going to compare two fictitious individuals the
first one is this inuit from northern canada and
here's the inward engaged in food production and
here's the inlet engaged in housing construction
and here's the inlet engaged in transportation
and i won't compare want to compare the inuit to
modern man and i want to ask who has more know-how
and i'm sure you feel that that's kind of
like a weird question right because this
guy knows this guy here oops knows how to hunt
knows how to fish knows how to make igloos etc
and if you bring this guy here to
the arctic we are sure he'll die
we don't know if he'll starve to death or if
he will freeze to death but he'll not survive
right moreover this guy uses
glasses uses headphones uses shirt
uses watch uses a computer uses a screen
he doesn't know how to make any of that
so there is no sense in which you can say that
this guy has more know-how than these other guys
but it is possible to say that the
society to which this guy belongs
knows how to make more things than the society
to which these guys belong because the society
to which this guy belongs knows how to
make shirts watches computers screens etc
well he doesn't he knows how to
make a miniscule fraction of that
the society to which these guys belong everybody
in the society knows how to hunt how to make
the igloo and so the punchline of the example
i'm putting here is that a society knows more
not because it's a society of geniuses superman
that are superior and so on a society knows more
because individuals know different
it's as if each one of us had a certain you know
cpu a certain capacity in our brains right and
if you fill all the brains with the
same information with the same knowledge
then the whole knows the same as each one but if
you put different knowledge in different heads
right then then the whole is going to know more
than than the parts so it's this emergent property
of collective knowledge that i'm going to try to
emphasize as sort of like the driving story here
so i'm going to try to understand what needs to
happen when this a system grows its knowledge base
for example this is you know the logo that
pays my salary and harvard was founded in 1636.
mind you that was before newton and physics
before lavoisier in chemistry before lineals
and biology before lock and hume and so on and
before darwin i can go on you know just
showing that i can mention these people yeah
but um the point here is that a if you are going
to have more knowledge you have to store it
somewhere right so for example harvard was founded
in this building but obviously now with all of
these things we need to teach we need more
buildings and we need more buildings right
and we need more buildings so we can imagine how
you know buildings grow to store that knowledge
but in 1636 a college degree lasted four years
now you could imagine that with so much more to
teach now you know graduation would look like this
but it doesn't right and why
doesn't it well it doesn't because
we don't have all our lives to acquire information
so it still lasts for years but we've decided to
create all these majors in at the university and
that doesn't count all the different majors that
mit offers down the road right so the system has
adjusted through this division of knowledge okay
okay so i'm going to assume that you know there is
a certain comfort amount of knowledge that sort of
like comfortably fits in the head okay so no the
dentist is not the lawyer right there's you know
there's some people who are super able they
tend to be at the santa fe institute they're
outside the norm but you know the rest of us you
know we we we can learn of a certain amount right
but the society as a whole can accumulate
orders of magnitudes of more knowledge okay so
i'm going to assume that the amount of knowledge
that fits in the head i'm going to call it a
person bite i call it a person bite because
i don't know how big it is so i cannot say
a gigabyte a megabyte a terabyte whatever i
don't know so let's call it a person line so
if a product requires more than one person
bite it cannot be done by one person
right so if it's a product that requires more than
one it will in one person but it will have to be
done by a team of people that cooperate in the
process of production okay and these things is
what we call firms that's where you know we
aggregate the knowledge of different people and
because that's not enough for example typically
a firm doesn't know how to make the inputs that
it uses it has to connect to the people who are
going to supply those inputs and so those are
other people that also are teams of people that
are trying to do this so in that sense the economy
is sort of like an aggregation of a processes
where we add knowledge to the production process
to transform the world in ways that we want it to
be so i'm going to show you how different products
require kind of different social organizations
this is a subsistence farming family in ecuador
and i show you this picture because this is
these are the things that they survive on and
these are the things that they make so the
knowledge necessary to make these things
resides in this family and they are sort of
self-sufficient to a first approximation maybe
they have some surpluses of some of these things
and they use it to buy matches and kerosene and
other things like that maybe these pots and pans
but essentially they're pretty self-sufficient
these are also family businesses but none
of them is like self-sufficient like none
of them on their own can make a hamburger right
because you need both the butcher and the baker
but you can imagine that this is a
production unit that fits in a family
the knowledge necessary to make
these things the family can have
no families can make these products there's just
too much knowledge necessary to make this product
and in some sense you can say that no country can
make this product this is the boeing 787 it's made
across all of these countries through all of
these companies it's called the boeing but if
you see boeing is this color i don't know what's
called this color fosha or i don't know they make
barely a few parts of of the whole thing right
you know the landing gear is a very complicated
piece the turbines the skin the wings etc etc this
imagine all the people that have to collaborate
their skills and knowledge not because
they're going to make many airplanes
they would need it just to make one airplane
okay so it's this aggregation of knowledge
that's behind these things so it's not about
scale in the sense that this is a big company
it's a big company but essentially everybody's
doing the same thing so you can move them around
and nothing happens right everybody's
sort of like using the same person bite
if you move people around here
you will hear the difference
so i'm going to try to capture this idea that we
put different bits of knowledge in different heads
so that the whole can know more than the parts
i'm going to try to capture it with the idea of
the scrabble model scrabble
model of economic development
it's like a game we need products to
survive and these products are words that is
think of them as meaningful words not like wordle
right now gibberish etc things that actually
perform a function so it's a meaningful word
and and so these productive capabilities these
knowledge units or these productive capabilities
are like letters and then we combine them to make
words okay so if you only have one letter
there aren't too many words you can make
if i now give you these three
letters now you can make four words
and you can make three letter words
if i just give you one extra letter
now you can make nine words if i
give you 10 letters we checked in the
scrabble website it says you can make 595
words and you can make 10 little words so the
more letters you have the more products you can
make and the longer the words you can make the
more complex the products it can make the more
knowledge intensive products you can make okay
so let's go back to this picture what
do we see now well who has more know-how
sounds like the same question about
uh the inuit and modern man right
this guy he knows how to make his own
tools he takes care of his own bulls he
makes he probably uses his own seeds he he
probably makes his own fertilizer with dung
this guy just manages uh you know knows how to
drive a harvester he doesn't know how to make
a harvester he doesn't know how to make the
fuel that the harvester uses it doesn't know
how to make the genetically modified seeds that
he's harvesting he doesn't know how to make the
fertilizers the agrochemicals he doesn't know
how to make any of that okay he is a letter
in a very long word this guy is a very short
word so the difference in these two production
processes is in the amount of knowledge that
they're mobilizing in the process of production
okay so how do we take this to
develop a theory of the world well
we're essentially saying is that you know
the world is composed of these kind of like
these productive capabilities this ability
is to do some transformations on the world
which are these letters and there are places in
the world that have subsets of these letters some
places have more complete a sample of the alphabet
some has a fewer letters in the alphabet and so
their products are just combination of
these letters so some products are long
like pharmaceuticals and cell phones some are
are short like hat and match which is just like
a hat with an m and a c right and and the chair is
just the same but with an an i and an r right so
so you see that products you know longer words
are are are going to be a part of the story here
but if for places to be able to make these
products they have to have the words that
the product needs that the word requires so we
can imagine that places are characterized by
the letters that they have and products are
characterized by the letters that they need
and so places are going to be able to
make the products for which they have
the right letters okay so some are going to
be able to make more products like this one
that has most letters are going to be making all
products the hard products to make the long words
pharmaceuticals and cell phones they are only
made by this country that has a lot of letters
well the hat is made by everybody because
everybody has all those three letters
right so this gives us the idea that if maybe we
cannot observe these letters maybe these letters
are sort of like the genetic code but we are not
at the present moment we are so like in the middle
of the 19th century when mendel was doing genetics
and he was assuming that there was some genes but
he didn't know their existence and he was trying
to infer what what would be observable if if
these genes existed so let's assume that we can't
observe these letters um but we think more or less
what they are but we don't have the data to prove
it say can how far can i get by just looking at
this thing here who makes what to infer who has
what letters or how many letters do they have okay
and how can i infer what products are difficult
to make and what products are hard to make
well so i'm going to assume that if a country has
a lot of letters it should be able to make many
words so this one is making five this one is
making three and this one is making only one
by the same token i can ask myself the question
if a product is a long word it requires
many letters it must be hard to make so
the harder it is to make the product the fewer
the countries that will be able to make it the
longer the word the fewer the countries to have
what it takes to make it so these two products
are only made by one country these two products
are made by two countries and this product is made
by all three countries so by looking at how many
things a place does and how many other places are
able to do the things that this place does there's
information about how complete is the electricity
okay so so the intuition is the more letters you
have the more words you make it the longer the
the word the fewer the countries that have what it
takes to make it and consequently the more letters
you have simultaneously simultaneously more stuff
you will be doing and stuff that is done in fewer
places okay and that's what we should observe in
the world if this whole stuff holds any water so
let's check this is how many how diversified our
countries how many products they make and this
is how many other countries make the stuff that
you make and lo and behold we find all the rich
countries are over here they make many things and
things that few other countries were able to make
and all the poor countries are over here they make
few things and things that everybody knows how to
okay so this is a feature it's not like you
know some countries the rich countries do a lot
per capita and other countries do a little per
capita no they change systematically in the things
they're able to do and this is not only true at
the level of countries we've looked at a bunch of
within countries at a bunch of places these
are chilean municipalities and here you have
the municipalities around santiago so they make
many things and things that are done in a few
places and here's you know where the penguins
live and so on no so they make few things and
things that are done everywhere these are mexican
states same story these are in turkish cities
these are states in colombia these are districts
in sri lanka wherever we go we the first thing we
look is you know what does this country know how
to do where does it know how to do it how much how
many letters are in in the different parts of this
thing so with this thing we've developed you know
some indices of how many letters a product has
and so we can rank you know products with a lot
of letters or we call them complex okay so they
they so like embody more knowledge and using our
methods you know how many countries make are able
to make these products and how diversified are the
countries that make these products and so on we
can rank products in terms of you know from more
complex to less complex and it sort of like kind
of makes sense we can also rank countries in terms
of how many letters they have and this is sort
of like our index of economic complexity so it
would give you some satisfaction to know that the
us beats canada in terms of the number of letters
not in hockey but you know um that you know uh
you know western europe germany france are quite
complex that south africa is the more complex
country in in southern africa that you know mexico
has more letters than my own country here etc so
kind of like makes sense we can check whether it
makes sense in terms of you know the income per
capita of these countries so here we have the
index of economic complexity and here we have the
income per capita in blue you have countries that
are not very rich in natural resources and for
them the relationship seems to be very tight right
a very good fit of the data the red countries
are rich in natural resources relatively rich
in natural resources they tend to be above the
blue countries that is if you think of this as
the number of letters you have they for those
the number of letters you have they're richer
well and why well because they their part of their
income is coming from these natural resources but
if you control for these natural resources you get
this relationship which is not you know not bad
you know you say no not bad you know there's maybe
something to the story of scrabble and and so on
you might say well but you know professor
houseman you know your theory has some errors
right in the sense that not all countries line
on top of this this line you know and if i were
a little bit more arrogant
i would say errors my theory
the world is wrong so what do we mean by the
world is wrong that if the world is wrong
it means that a country if i can measure
their letters i can sort of like predict
how rich it should be and if it's not rich today
then it will be tomorrow canada like is able to
predict where a country is going even before the
country gets there and so we've shown that in
these deviations say this is india here it says
the theory says india how are you so poor given
how much you know you should be up there well
maybe that's one of the reasons why india is
one of the fastest growing countries in the world
this by the way was done with 2008 data greece is
up here no the theory would say greece how did
you get to be so rich given how little you know
er well guess what you know
greece is not as rich anymore right so so actually
we've shown that these quote-unquote error terms
really capture something more fundamental
about where these countries are going
so okay so so now i've started to get excited
because now we sort of like get a handle on
we want to make places more prosperous we
need to get them more letters right get
more letters more words longer words we have
a path forward now how are we going to do that
well to do this we need to solve
this chicken and egg problem
now for the knowledgeable people in
the audience they will have realized
that this is not a chicken but a rooster
but you know it's what i found on the web so
and what's the nature of the chicken and
egg problem the nature of the chicken
and egg problem is that you cannot make
the things that you don't know how to do
and you typically don't know how to do the
things you don't do you cannot make watches
without watchmakers but how the hell do you become
a watchmaker in a place that doesn't make watches
so this is going to be a damper on the
process of knowledge accumulation okay
so the way the world solves this problem one one
of the strategies the world has found to solve
this problem is related to this classification
problem and this classification problem
is i want to know which two animals are sort
of like closely related to each other and which
animal is out of the group so depending on on
the theory with which you see the world you
would have said well you know the lion and the
zebra are both from africa and the bear is not
or you know the lion and bear eat complicated
stuff a zebra only eats grass but here we're going
to use the scrabble theory and according to the
scrabble theory the zebra is just a bear with a z
so if you want to go from bear to zebra you
just need to solve one chicken and egg problem
if you want to go from bear to lion you have
to solve four chicken and neck problems the
four letters you have are useless and
the four letters you need you don't have
so this gives us a sense of what
transitions are easier more likely etc
but one way to think about this
problem is to think that every product
exists in some technology space and i
want you to think of this technology space
as a forest where every product is like a
tree and in that forest the bear and the zebra
are kind of like close to each other because
they use more or less the same letters but but
the lion is in a different part of the forest
and that what we want is a map of this forest
and i had in my mind this idea
of the of the forest and so on
and in 2007 i was able to publish this paper with
cesar hidalgo laszlo barabasi and bailey klinger
in science that had the map of the forest
and this is the map of the forest
here every circle is a product
and this product is connected to other products
through our measure of how similar they are
and we measure how similar
they are by the fact that
you know all countries that make left-hand side
shoes tend also to make right-hand side shoes
right but the ones that make left hands
i choose very seldom make x-ray machines
right so that in the probability that
things are co-produced there's some
indication that they must be using the same
letters when you average overall countries
so this stuff you know started to orient us
this here by the way are garments you see
they're very tightly connected it means that if
you know what it if you have what it takes to
make one kind of garment you can sort of figure
out how to make other kinds of garments this is
processed food these are construction materials
this is machinery these are chemicals these are
electronics and then there's a periphery of
poorly connected products like as a venezuelan
i'm concerned here is oil it's sort of like at
the end of the world there's nothing near it
so we're starting now to see you know this
technology starts to be something a little
bit more concrete now that's technology but i
don't care about technology per se i care about
countries so what is a country a country is a
collection of teams that can make some stuff okay
so in this metaphor a country is a collection of
monkeys that live in certain parts of the forest
okay so a i can look at my own country and
here's the product space and putting color
the things where venezuela has sufficient
knowledge to be able to make the stuff and
sell it abroad so that we can see it okay so
this is venezuela this is mexico you might
say well venezuela mexico they all speak spanish
must be like the same there are many more lights
in mexico than venezuela so this is an indication
there's much more knowledge has diffused in
mexico than in venezuela you might say well but
mexico is a country of 120 130 million people
uh maybe it's because mexico is big so let's
go to a smaller country say let's go to austria
and this is austria so you kind of like
do everything and austria is a country
of less than 10 million people right so
it's not about the number of people okay
say okay so now we have we have a way of
representing the knowledge of our country by the
way all of this is in our website google atlas
of economic complexity and you can look at any
country and you can do all of these things for any
year and a bunch of other things and all the stuff
i'm going to present today it's all implemented
and by the way it's at a reasonable price of zero
so but we don't want to just tell
you what a country knows how to do
we want to change the world right we want
to guide them in a certain direction right
help them so like conquer the forest so we
have to ask the questions do these monkeys jump
and um so to tell you that story
i'm going to compare two countries
one is ghana and one is thailand they both
started back in 1962 with very similar incomes
we can look at what they were doing well before i
tell you that let me tell you one extra piece of
information and that's that ghana improved their
educational attainment much faster than thailand
they both were improving but sort of like ghana
beat thailand in terms of improving education
and in addition education in ghana is in
english education in thailand is in thai and
you know there are some advantages of speaking
english in a world where it's the lingua franca
so let's figure out what was ghana doing in
1962 well donna was doing cocoa beans cocoa
butter cocoa paste nuts coffee wood some diamonds
so all very i agricultural or mineral products
and these were thailand exports in 1962.
okay so it's rice maize flour rice rubber
tin jute so a little bit more diversified but
and so like the same kind of products right
agriculture or minerals and this is where they
were in the product space and putting sort of
like a highlighting the the places where each
country had monkeys in 1962 1965 here okay so now
i'm going to pass you a movie and i want you to be
you know paying close attention here to see where
are these monkeys moving so no so those are the
monkeys so i'm going to show you monkeys moving
okay so 65 70 75 80 85 19 95 2000 2005 2010.
okay maybe i went too fast so let me go back okay
so a you see a couple of monkeys not too
far from this garment cluster now they get
two monkeys here in the garment cluster boom
the monkeys jump all over the garment cluster
boom they will they've taken over all the garments
cluster and now i have these two monkeys here
in the electronics cluster and well now
they've taken over all the electronics
cluster right and they're starting to move
here into the central machinery cluster so
now they've grown more here and they've
started to abandon the garments cluster because
they have better things to do in the
meantime very little has happened in ghana
so this was ghana's exports in 1962 as i showed
you before and these are ghana's exports today so
there's been transformation you
know even from cocoa bean raw
here is cocoa bean raw here's butter and paste
here is cocoa powder so they've diversified a
little bit you see the colors haven't changed much
a little bit no no in they discovered a gold mine
and this is their exports per capita in
constant dollars okay see that it really
hasn't gone anywhere this was thailand
in 1962 and this is thailand today okay
and this these were their exports in 1962 there
were about a hundred dollars per capita another
like 3 500. so they went up by a factor of 35
in real per capita terms so that's that's the
transformation that is underpinning this increase
in income so when you look at incomes per capita
these two countries have diverged but
they have diverged because of something
that was happening to the process of knowledge
accumulation to the monkeys colonizing the forest
okay so this gives us a theory of how we explain
growth in the world and the first part of our
theory is very simple it says are you above the
line or below this line that i showed you before
right and the second part of the theory would
say are your monkeys close to empty trees
as you know you saw the venezuelan monkeys were
very few and they were all in the periphery
mexico had more monkeys right
and then austria had taken
whole the whole forest so how close
are your monkeys to empty trees
and so here is how many letters you have oops and
here is how close are your monkeys to empty trees
so here are countries that have very few
letters and are very far from empty trees
and my own country unfortunately is over here
er then there are a bunch of countries that have
an intermediate number of letters and they're
close to many mp3s here here india is great but
greece is also great so it's not the same story
as before this is a different metric it's so how
easy it would be to go from bear to zebra in this
country how many zebras are close to your bears
and then austria is over here they've taken over
all the forests so there's no empty trees there's
not nothing for them to to jump into of things
that exist if they want to make progress that
they will have to invent things that don't yet
exist they'll have to kind of plant new trees
they'll have to do innovation at the technological
frontier so this gives us a very simple two by
two matrix here is do you have more than
enough letters to be richer than you are
and this is is it easy for you to acquire more
letters by going parsimoniously from bear to zebra
so there are some countries here that you know
haven't made they have more than enough letters
to be richer than they are and on top of that
it's easy for them to get more letters by just
going from pair to zebra there are other
countries that it's hard for them to get
more letters but they still have some juice
to get from the letters that they have then
there are some countries that need more letters
but it's relatively easy for them to get them
and then there are countries that
need more letters but it's hard for
them to get them they need you know
a bridge over troubled waters so it's
and i bet when i show this to my
students they tell me that it dates me
so since we've done this all empirically i
can tell you where these countries are so
lo and behold india and china are
over here that's the reason why they
have been growing so fast my own poor country
is over here right greece is over here
and so on so so this is at least one approach
the idea let's try to move from bear to zebra and
let's see how far we can get there and by the way
in the in in the website it will tell you which
products are nearby and how sexy they are etc so
so to orient the monkeys are where they need to go
now another part of our research was to say okay
so you cannot make watches without watchmakers
it's hard to become a watchmaker it's
hard to move no know-how into brains
move brains right and we've done this at
different scales and there's a whole literature
contributed by many other people but
in in in my team uh frank nefcke lubitzarne
have all worked on showing at different scales
that the movement of people is central to the
movement of knowledge both between firms
that you know the founders of many of the
companies in silicon valley all work for fairchild
semiconductors right the founders of many of the
car companies all worked at oldsmobile and then at
ford right it was sort of like that's where they
got trained that's where the the wiring of the
brain happened and then they they moved with their
brains right and it happens between countries
so migration is central there are papers that
show that you know scientific development of the
us was significantly accelerated by the european
refugees that happened in the context of the
second world war and and anti-semitism and so on
um so so moving brains is an important thing and
by the way a poor countries are incredibly close
to high-skill immigration they don't let
them in there's no many of them don't have
path to permanent residence to citizenship
to to professional accreditation
foreigners cannot be hired in many positions
professions are close to so countries are you know
shooting themselves in the foot big time i think
this is the biggest 500 bill lying on the ground
and we've been working on
different countries analyzing
what their system is like and to see if we can
make it a little bit more attractive of talent so
finally i want to say something about inequality
because inequality is is you know is important to
everybody we would like to live in a fairer
society and the question is can we can we
extract from this scrabble story from this as
you see this increasing complexity this idea that
you know society is like a social brain that
puts different bits of knowledge in different
heads and then has to put humpty dumpty
back together again has to network them
back together so you see how economic
complexity naturally emerges from this
view that there's an emerging
property at the level of society
that that comes from the interaction of these
individual parts does this also explain inequality
so here i'm going i hope i don't scare you with
the next slide but david told me don't worry these
people are really very sophisticated they're
not going to get scared okay so here's a slide
so the slide says this is the fraction of the
alphabet you have and on the y-axis is this is
the fraction of the dictionary you can write
okay given say the alphabet has 26 letters how
many words can you make if you have half of those
letters do you make half the words do you make
10 of the words how many words can you make
with a certain fraction of the alphabet
and the answer like all answers in economics
it depends it depends on the nature of the
grammar right in this case the nature of the
technology if all words are one letter long
then we're home free you have one letter you
make one word you have 10 letters you make
10 words you have 100 letters you make 100
words so a relationship would be very linear
if products are complex it's words are
long say the words are 10 letters long
if if you have five letters how
many words can you make zilch zero
and if you have nine letters how many words can
you make still zero right if you have ten letters
maybe you can make one but now if you have eleven
now you have eleven choose ten that's eleven
and you know if you have 12 that's 12 choose 10
that's 66 and so suddenly it starts growing a lot
okay so in this paper with cesar hidalgo we
we developed the model and we found a way to
estimate it for this world i mean these are all
possible worlds how does it look for this world
and it depending on the dataset we use it all
looks very convex and this is a bummer okay i
mean this is a headache this is a real tragedy
for humanity if you want this is what makes
what makes life difficult and that's that
if you think of the slope of these curves
that's sort of like how much bang would you get
from an extra letter so if you have few letters
it doesn't pay much to get an extra letter because
you cannot combine that letter with many other
letters so but if you have a lot of letters and
i give you one extra letter then it you know
11 to 10 then you know that now you can make a
lot right so so this is a machine of inequality
and this is something that is going to want
these letters to get close to each other
okay and we know that they do get close to each
other because this is sort of like you know
you've all been to new york you know without
a subway the city wouldn't operate right
and this is sort of like a
map of economic densities and
that's canada this is italy this is in the
u.s in so the activities in the world are
very concentrated as there's few places with a
lot of letters so let's just try to congregate
and we try to see if we could explain say
poverty and inequality in other parts of
of the world so here is we did this study on
mexico and these are the income per capita of
the different states in in mexico and this is
what i showed you in the in the first graph and
you know when i spoke about nogales arizona sonora
the poorest state in mexico is a state of chiapas
so let's look within chiapas to the
different municipalities of chiapas
so it's not that chiapas is poor is
that chiapas also you know zoom in
you have this enormous
inequality between municipalities
so we asked ourselves you know
why the hell is chiapas poor
and you know there are standard stories well
they're probably less educated they're probably
more indigenous population they're probably maybe
maybe the problem is that japanecos are weird
right so is there a way that we can check
whether chapanecos are particularly weird
well one way that occurred to us is to ask
how much does a chiapaneco earn in chiapas
versus at chiapaneco outside of
chiapas so if you call 100 what
say a mexican non-japaneco mexican
earns in his state archia paneko earns
60. okay and that's controlling for you know
schooling school and quality experience gender
indigenous status and so on so controlling
for everything else people earn almost half
in chiapas vis-a-vis the rest of mexico so you
say okay how much would they earn if they are
outside of chiapas and say well then you're
cheating here because we know that migrants
are probably more entrepreneurial okay so it's not
fair it's okay okay but they're not only japanese
migrants they're also other migrants so let's look
at other mexicans that have migrated out of their
state and there is you know the the people
who migrate earn about fourteen percent more
so let's compare the chiapanekos that migrated
to the mexicans that migrated fiends feels like a
fair comparison and there what we find is that
they are indistinguishable so the problem
is not the people the problem is the place
okay it'll be our argument the problem is
not the people the problem is the place okay
um so we went out and calculated for all the
municipalities of mexico and there are several
couple of thousand municipalities how many
letters each municipality have and then we
try to estimate can we explain the difference
in incomes between different municipalities and
ask ourselves why is chiapas poor maybe it is
because they have a less educated labor force
and they do have a less educated labor force
and that explains this much of this difference
maybe it's because their education is of lower
quality and yes part of it is that maybe it's
because their education and math is lower quality
so a little bit you know some of it is education
then a little bit is that they are younger
so they have not accumulated more experience
it's not because more women work in chiapas and
women earn less less women will work in chiapas so
this works in the other direction um they are more
indigenous and indigenous people controlling for
other things earned less but the bulk it's also
more rural state but the bulk of the explanation
is that they have fewer letters there is
the problem of the chiapanekos and chiapas
is that they're like the letter l and
they're surrounded by a bunch of letter l's
and with the letter l there
aren't too many words you can do
but if they leave chiapas they go to a place
where they can mix their letter l with a bunch
of other letters and participate in a bunch
of other things but if they aren't chiapas
they can't do that so access to letters that
is uh the ability to combine your letter with
other letters is is a fundamental aspect
of these large differences in productivity
and this has to do with things like you know
this is one technology to transport energy
this is another technology to transport
energy right and this is one technology to
transport water and this is another technology
to transport water so your ability to connect
to these networks is going to be an important
determinant of the things you want to do if
you want to connect to the network of the labor
market your ability to connect your labor with
other people well this is one way to go to work
right and this is another way to go to work so
there is a lot of discussion when people talk
about inequality of the idea that the world is
unfair because the pie is poorly distributed and
what i'm arguing here is that there's really not
one pie that there's inequality in the sizes
of the pies that different parts or different
places or different organizations are able
to put together so in other words there's
inequality in productivity it's not just that
there's one kind of like big productivity and
then people take different shares is that
there's enormous inequality in productivity
and this leads to an important point and that is
that if the balcony inequality is in productivity
then redistribution is something that only
compensates people i mean inequality is
about productivity and productivity is about your
inability to connect your letters to other letters
redistribution only compensates people for
their exclusion in some sense it's palliative
while inclusion is curative it's about empowering
people with their ability to you know connect to
participate in this process of of of creating
longer words both are expensive so it's if you
have limited resources you have to sort of choose
between more redistribution versus more inclusion
you know you'd have to empower endow people
with you know access to infrastructure access
to education access to the job market etc
so that they can become more productive
and so i think that this is um you know the
difficult part of the story and where we need
to break our heads trying to figure out how
can we make a world a fairer place given this
you know difficult mechanics of of the fact that
complexity wants to you to put all the letters
somewhere and not to put some letters everywhere
and that tension between putting all letters
somewhere so we can do a lot with letters in that
place versus putting some letters everywhere but
then nobody's able to make much because with
few letters you cannot make much that tension
is a central tension i think in doing serious work
about making the world a fair place so let me just
sum up by saying economic development results from
the adoption of technology and technology is tools
codes and know-how tools and codes are relatively
easy to move know-how is the hardest one to move
because it only you know malcolm
gladwell in the 10 000 hours
societies accumulate know-how by putting
different bits of know-how in different
brains and societies know more because individuals
know different and adopting technologies faces
this chicken and neck problem that the world has
discovered one way of solving it is by moving
from bear to zebra moving to you know stuart
kaufman would have called the adjacent possible
countries differ enormously in how easy
it is for them to move in that space
depending on where they are through whatever
historical process got them where they are
new know-how enters the system through some
process of infection you know um semiconductor
technology got to silicon valley because william
shockley moved from from new jersey with a group
of of people that that became you know ended up
at fairchild and then created intel and all these
other institutions so it's a process of infection
that we should try to encourage right and then
and and the system is not just idea it's not if
i had invented the world i would have made it up
easier to be more just and more equal
we have to understand the sources of
inequality that are inherent in this
idea that letters want to be together
and we haven't found ways for people
to interact in longer words maybe now
with the pandemic that we have learned to
do things through soon and that people can
do telework and so on we're actively exploring
the new possibilities that this is going to open
etc so we're but but it is a problem that
needs you know people to be thinking hard
and check out our website and thank you guys
very much i'm sure i passed over my time with
so if anyone in the audience
has a question for ricardo
my friend mark has a question for you ricardo
thank you so much your discussion of not
being able to bring your know-how back home
um reminded me of when i finished my phd in the
us and i tried to go back home and i was told that
the people who stayed home would be given
the jobs so i ended up in los alamos and said
i had a question for you about trying to transfer
know-how in post-war soviet times they transferred
a lot of professionals to soviet cities a classic
example is kasparov who had a russian father an
armenian mother and grew up in azerbaijan um
is there any study of how successful that was
from the point of view of the kind of distribution
you're talking about well i don't know too much
about that example but i do i have done over the
years a lot of work on kazakhstan actually i'm
going there next week um and and there's a big
there's a city in kazakhstan called karaganda
and karaganda is famous because it was the
biggest gulag in the soviet union and in
a lot of scientists poets etc went to
karaganda and some of them kind of like stayed
and there's studies that show that the knowledge
stuck that is that i don't recommend gulags
let me clarify but this is
sort of like an example of that
there are many more beneficial
examples or not no laos examples in
you know in i think it was 1685 uh louis
xiii um revoked the edict of nantes
a of religious toleration and sir like told the
pro french protestants who called the juggernauts
that either they converted or they had to
leave and many many hundreds of thousands left
and we know where they left and we know what
happened we can see from 1685 onwards it was the
elector of brandenburg he passed a decree saying
we'll take them so they went many to brandenburg
and some of them went on some villages and towns
in brandenburg and not in others so people have
done very careful analysis this comes from a
fantastic research called petra melser who she's
at nyu and uh and it's sort of like very well
identified and and those places not only acquire
technologies that they brought from france but
develop technologies in the subsequent centuries
and it was a big infusion of of know-how to
germany and 400 of them went to south africa
and 167 of them went to stellenbosch
and a place called france hook
which in doctrine in afrikaans means french
corner now guess what they make there
wine so the wine culture went to south africa
in the head of if you want protestant refugees
so so there are examples like that of of uh the
movement of of know-how there are others more
well in the paper i did with um
uh lubizza nadelkoska we looked at albania
and you know with the collapse of communism
half a third of the population of albania left
the country about 40 of those went to greece
and in 2011 greece got into serious trouble uh so
many of those that had left to greece returned it
was a big shock because it increased the labor
force of albania by five percent in two years
so it was a big increase in in in
inflow of people and you would have said
well you know an economist would say well it's
obvious what's going to happen either wages go
down so that these people get employed now that
there's more of them right and if wages don't go
down then there'll be unemployment so either wages
go down or unemployment goes up what ended up
happening wages went up and unemployment went down
and the reason was that when they were in greece
they were working in the agricultural sector with
technologies that were not present in albania
they were working in the tourism sector with
when they came back they brought they couldn't
leave their brains behind so so they came with
their know-how and that know-how implied that
they had ideas of things to do and in order to
execute them they had to hire their neighbors
so actually it was positive for the employment
of the non-migrants and so that's like those
there are many other examples with frank nefcke
and and dario de gato we have a paper on a
involuntary refugees to mexico i mean these
are the people that were kicked out of the u.s
and we find that the industries in the towns they
came from the industries where they had acquired
experience in the us tend to do better when they
go back so so there's a lot of evidence that
this movement of brains is quite quite central
thank you for a terrific presentation i
i'd like to hypothesize a possible response
that the authors of why nations fail
might make to your original setup
let's say that everything you said is true
um couldn't they say we were making a slightly
different point you were being a neo-adam smith
imagining um factors of production with a much
more nuanced model than what he had to work with
so you were kind of giving an ideal version of
productivity and various relationships and and
this and that couldn't they say we were making not
so much a purely economic point but a political
economic point which is which goes to their
kind of overarching distinct distinction between
extractive and i can't remember what the other
term inclusive inclusive economies right and um
i mean it's possible for for uh it seems
to me everything you said to be true
but if you have a regime that is extractive
it's going to put the brakes on so so
maybe their you know nogales
nogales example isn't perfect but
um it's an illustration yeah it's an illustration
and so couldn't both of your points be true so
you know i come from venezuela so i do believe
that politics can destroy your country so
but i come from also a different experience
say both in my previous experience in venezuela
when i was there and my experience as chief
economist of the inter-american development bank
and in the 22 years i've been at harvard i've
worked with say i don't know 40 some countries
i would characterize many of these places as
having very serious governments that are trying to
get things right and presumably that's one of
the reasons why they want to talk to me and that
and i want to talk to them right though you know
they took economies that were in trouble with
high inflation debt crisis and so on transformed
into economies with low inflation investment grade
you know improving in all the indicators left
and right and they're not growing and that's
what sort of like drove me to this question i can
imagine the countries that that have are in the
middle of a war with you know a lot of et cetera
that these things are going to have you know it's
obvious why they're not growing but there are
too many countries that i see are get stuck
with no obvious defects and the question
is what could they be doing different
and i think that their approach is to say
something it's all the institutions but not
the policies because the policies are endogenous
to the institutions and the institutions
has something to do with what happened in the 15th
century so you had a bad 15th century you know
you have no future and there's very lit it's very
hard to go from their framework to any action plan
um and i think that that's not even their
attempt i think that in exploiting you
know it's a little bit like people say you know
there's genetic variation between individuals so
so you know the others say well there might
be genetic variations between individuals but
for the part that is not determined by genetics
let's get as much from it as we can right so
maybe there's something some original sin that
your country has has inherited what else can
you be doing to generate more prosperity and i
hope that you see that in my framework there is
a way of answering that question and there's
a way of thinking to in paths to prosperity
yes thank you very much for a very inspiring
thought thought-provoking uh lecture uh
i i see that you have in your summing up
there's some implied policy uh advice but
could you be more specific about what we
do with this and in particular uh advice
for international organizations for uh donor
countries and and so forth and in that regard
of course there has been efforts international
efforts to for knowledge sharing the one that
i'm most familiar with is the international
centers for agricultural research uh that's that's
at least survived for a long time uh thank
you very much so um i i you know i have great
respect for these institutions i spent seven
years at the inter-american development bank
i've worked with a world bank in the
imf in many different countries and
usually i'm on the side of the government
helping the government negotiate
with or or helping the government decide what
they want to do with these institutions but
in general i think that these institutions
are well intentioned and they are executing
a certain strategy that comes from a
certain theory that they have in their minds
okay and i have a problem with those theories for
example they there was for a long time the idea
that if you just you know get out of the way
and prove the macro improve the education
open up to trade don't mess too much with the
economy things will take care of themselves
and i think that it just doesn't work that
way because there are these chicken and neck
problems uh that need need coordination to be
solved that countries are typically you know
one of the things i didn't talk about is that
some of these letters that you need to make words
are what we call in economics public goods they
cannot be provided by the markets they have to be
provided by governments and governments are fairly
lousy in providing the letters that existing
activities need they are hopeless at providing
the letters that activities that don't exist
need there's no one knocking at their door but
that would exist had they provided those letters
so there's a very active potential policy of a
policy is that would encourage economic
growth i look at this region of the u.s
i don't think that arizona would be where
it is and new mexico would be where it is
without the presence of significant institutions
created here by the federal government
right now now that the federal government
would have probably been a huge part of
the economy in the 1940s and 50s but then
it sort of like created a crisp a seed on which
a big crystal could grow so i do think that um
we need to figure out what what
governments can do to facilitate
the growth process i have shown in other research
that education is very different from know-how
education is what we teach every it's sort of like
what everybody knows the same right and all these
standardized exams is we ask the same question
to everybody and the growth of know-how that
i described is this diversification of knowledge
not everybody knowing the same and i've shown that
when you make a horse race between say education
and and this diversification of knowledge
in some sense you saw it in the chiapas example
it was not education that was doing the work it
was this diversification of knowledge and and the
only way to diversify knowledge is not by having
super duper teachers that know more than one
person but a teacher cannot have more than one
person by right it's people learn what what
to do in organizations that do it you learn
on the job and you cannot have experiences in
industries that don't exist right you cannot
become a watchmaker in a place that doesn't
make watches so all of these things create um
possibilities for government action to be very
important and i think that east asia has shown it
and i think that this lesser fair attitude
in latin america has come at a huge cost
i've been watching for a particular word and
you've used it twice and i think it's very
important and that word uh is war in particular
militarism and i think you know and it's a fact
that the united states spends on the military
uh more than the uh next nine countries do
how would militarism fit into your equations your
your way of viewing what the world is all about
so it's a it's a difficult question sort of like
there is two aspects to it in some sense you know
i think if the us was militarily not as strong as
it is and it didn't have this industrial structure
probably ukraine the ukraine war would have ended
in defeat and ukraine would no longer exist so
so you know my parents were holocaust survivors
my mother remembered always the day that she was
freed by usgis in in belgium so so you know there
is a role for for defense in in some scenarios
but one question is do military expenditures
resemble sort of like the egyptian
pyramids or do they resemble nasa in the sense
that the egyptian pyramids one really has
trouble imagining that they were really thought
as long-term investments in the tourism industry
right but but one knows that teflon and and velcro
and a bunch of things came out of nasa right so
i know that there are some studies
that show that israel military spending
has been central to their ability
to excel in r d so i would say
some darpa for example is a major component
of u.s success in technology so i i would say
let's not forget that you know defense is has
a role in in the world and we can discuss big
you know my colleague steve walt you know is
constantly arguing that the u.s is overdoing it
they're overreaching and that it's inefficient and
costly and that it gets into trouble and things
that it doesn't know how to problem and doesn't
know how to solve and i can have some sympathy for
that view but i want to balance it in the sense
that we have lived the pax americana and we don't
know what the world would look like without the
perception that there's somebody who's concerned
about keeping the global peace so but but part
of those expenditures have an element of of nasa
so we have a group of questions here
i think that if we allow all of them
we'll go over time so i say just go
for it one two three is that correct
okay um so my question is about
education um and the movement of brains
um so i'm from south africa and if i think back
to my friends from high school who then went on to
go to university in south africa almost
every single one of them has left
and you know you spoke a little bit about how
countries maybe their policies don't promote
brains coming in you know they make it hard
to get certifications and things like that but
how what what do you say about like
keeping the people that they're educating
um you know to a university level specialized
level and stopping them from sort of leaving
for opportunities and that kind of thing
well excellent question um i've been
working on south africa since 2004.
uh i was there a couple of months ago
and and we're actively doing work in in south
africa i've been particularly a focused on this
idea that south africa needs to focus on its
ability to attract talent in when i worked with
a south african government back in in the north
say around 2008 2009 we came up with a report
that analyzed a south african immigration
policy and we said that they we recommended
that they change it to be more open to foreign
talent there was a skill shortage in the country
and they were not letting skills into a country
um so we worked on a draft law the stuff went
to parliament and it came out worse than it got in
so so it was quite uh frustrating experience we're
trying to work on the same topics right now now
in addition you talk about it's like discouraging
brains from staying and i think i think that's
uh an important issue in in south africa there's
something called black economic empowerment which
is an affirmative action program to encourage
black entrepreneurship black employment a black
in hiring at the more senior positions and so on
and uh you know given south africa's history
one can understand um you know the logic of
of trying to encourage a affirmative action
in in the economy but we have argued that in
new firms should be born without original sin
uh that you know it's already it's very easy for
the big mining companies and the big banks and the
big et cetera to abide by all of these affirmative
action regulations that are quite onerous
um but it's very hard for a startup to do it
so i mean there's a reason why elon musk
thought that maybe it would be easier in the us
so it's not that they didn't have the talent but
they didn't have the ecosystem and i think that
the country needs to is we're working
on a strategy with them that we call
growth through inclusion that um it's not a battle
over redistributing the assets that are there
because you cannot expropriate know-how
see in in their mind not the current government
but the previous government of president zuma
they developed this narrative of something
that they called white monopoly capitalism
and they would view the world as being composed
of capital and labor and the owners of capital
owned the means of production and they're you
know exploiting a labor so what we need is to
expropriate the means of production but so you can
expropriate machines and companies and whatever
right but you cannot expropriate know-how so you
either some deal with it encourage it you know
nurture it attract it or you lose it and that's
the point you were making so i agree with you
that's my question now thanks so much for
an accessible and fascinating talk um i'm
wondering based on your findings i'm over here
um on the distribution because with these lights
i'm right next to you you're in the dark based
on the productivity and know-how distribution
among countries as the global economy moves to
decarbonizing the economy in the next several
decades to meet the paris agreement targets i'm
wondering if you have any sense of how that will
shift the distribution productivity if you
think that inequalities will be sort of further
exacerbated as we move away from fossil fuels or
if there's any hope for less produce to catch up
okay so let me tell you thank you thank
you thank you for this question because
it will allow me to say some
some really crazy things um
the narrative as you say you know
we need to meet the paris accords
you we need to do a b and c right and um i that
narrative is incredibly frustrating in places
that without constraints have not been able to
grow and now you're adding to the constraints
so it's to say yes you know whatever you were
doing now you have to do less because you have
to lower your emissions and so on i think that
that's the wrong frame and it's very castrating
and counterproductive we need the world
to decarbonize that is not achieved by
a every country decarbonizing every company
decarbonizing every individual decarbonizing
and you know there was some idea and i think
it's still being considered uh to publish
a the amount of co2 emissions that harvard
professors do when when they travel
and publish it and sort of like name and shame or
something like that so that we we change the moral
code of decarbonization we're going to decarbonize
the world through a technological revolution
and we need knowledge to decarbonize the world
and that's going to happen because there are
some new industries that don't exist today
that will have to be created some industries that
produce alternative energy industries that produce
green steel that produce green fertilizers that
produce green aluminum that produce green cement
that produce green they're
working no green uh air air
jet fuel etc right so we need we need a lot
of new industries that don't exist today
where are they going to be we know for example
that their best strategy to decarbonize is
to electrify anything that can be electrified
well there's no way of doing that without a
massive increase in mining we need a lot of more
copper a lot more aluminum to electrify everything
who's going to produce the copper and the aluminum
so right now we have you know the
peruvians and the chileans were an
important source of this stuff saying no no
we are green we don't want to do mining well
guess what then the price of these minerals goes
up er alternative energies electrification becomes
too expensive and we cannot decarbonize so we need
to carve out a role for the countries of the world
to help the world decarbonize to do things in
the countries that help the world decarbonize
we're working on namibia and namibia has a
huge project to use the namibian desert uh
and by the way the capital of namibia is called
vinduk which means wind corner so they have a
lot of sun and a lot of wind so there's a lot
of companies that want to go there to produce
green hydrogen maybe green ammonia then
to use hydrogen for direct reduction of
of iron ores to make you know to
to reduce the iron not using a
natural gas etc but using hydrogen made with solar
so there's plenty of growth opportunities if the
framing you go to one of these countries that
want to get forward is what is there going to
be the role in the green new industries of the
future how can they help the world decarbonize
and that i think is a growth agenda that can be
very important for in the coming years and i'm
i think we need to figure out how to make
this uh an opportunity for them to catch up
okay ricardo we have one i'm
sorry we have one last question
sure yes uh thank you very much for this very
interesting talk uh so i'm from the netherlands
and specifically from um norwegian that claims
it's the most intelligent region in the world um
and the way we this region has become
the most intelligent allegedly most
intelligent region in the world is because
they import a lot of people a lot of know-how
but this also means that that know-how
is exported from the rest of the world
so i was wondering what sort of your opinion
or your views are on this competition
between transfer of know-how between different
parts of the world and how importing know-how
in certain parts of the world will actually
extract know-how from other parts of the world
so i think it's a it's an excellent question um
first of all my spiel when i go to
the countries that i typically work with is i
tell them some statistics about silicon valley
i tell them look 54 of the stem workers
the science technology engineering and
math workers of silicon valley 54 are foreigners
and the other 46 percent are not californians
right even though california has 40 million
people which is more people than most of the
countries i work on 18 are californians
okay so silicon valley it was not done
on the basis of growing your talent it was
blown on the basis of attracting talent
and you know i lived in venezuela in in a period
in which the country became the richest country in
in the americas and we had massive
infusions of foreign talent
and it was central to the growth of the
country so um i think that if your country
i mean we did a major report
later maybe it was it was long
we did a report on on colombia it's on the
web you can google it on columbia diaspora
we're telling them look you have a diaspora of
5 million people including second generation
colombians uh you know it's not like if you were
open to immigration uh you were sort of like
they have like five million diaspora
and they had in 2015 150 000 foreigners
so it's not like if you allowed more people in
that it would be problematic right so actually
that they've done an enormous amount with the
venezuelan refugees and i commend them they've
given them temporary protection status they gave
them rights they gave them access to labor market
and and i think that they'll benefit from from
that experience so the first message is if you
if you cannot prevent your own people from
leaving don't prevent others from coming in
it's kind of like kind of obvious number two
is you don't necessarily want people to stay
the diaspora can be extremely valuable and
they're very interesting studies that show how
the diaspora can be transformative of the home
country you know the diaspora knows two worlds
they know the technology here they know
the technology there they can sort of like
identify gaps they can connect people they can
connect people to professional opportunities to
business opportunities so actually we've worked
on countries like sri lanka albania uh colombia
ethiopia on working on their diaspora
strategy there's some beautiful work
by analysing from berkeley on showing the
enormous impact that the indian diaspora the
taiwanese diaspora the korean diaspora
had on the home country and so
so even the people that have left you want them
engaged i don't want to presume anything but
the fact that i'm in the u.s i don't know that
it has meant that venezuela has lost something
that maybe i'm you know i can be more useful
to venezuela in some sense so so i think that
the brains by the way we did another paper with
frank lefke and miquela corsa on business travel
and we found huge effects of business travel and
productivity so so you want to focus on the idea
that brains are to be attracted used where
they you know where they sleep is not as
important as what they think and the fact that
they're thinking about you is useful to you
all right can we get one more round
of applause for crowder houseman
you